now the ukrainian crisis was a topic
that generated heated exchanges between
russia and the united states in munich
and our correspondent melinda crane
caught up with the conference chairman
wolfgang ischinger to get his take on
the tensions
this is the place where the reset button
was pushed supposedly utter ushering in
a new era of u.s russian cooperation but
frankly from the rhetoric here this year
was sounding more like a new era of cold
war
well you're right it's things aren't
what they should be
there is of course frustration
over
the inability to come to grips with
syria there is
anger and frustration
over
the dispute
the tug of war so to speak over ukraine
etc but let's face it we will need to
work with russia
and actually i believe russia knows that
they need to work with us with the
united states and with europe so i
regard this as one of the downs
and then there will be other ups again
so i don't think we should dramatize it
this is not a great moment of our
relationship with russia but better days
will come